our next speaker is a self trained wine
expert and he revolutionized the wine
industry in his Ren is admired for
creating a new generation of branding
focusing on the Internet and leveraging
social media tools here is the social
media Somali a Gary Vaynerchuk I'm gonna
use the chair as well I love social
media because it's sell [ __ ] actually I
have too much energy for this um
obsessed with storytelling I think we've
been sitting here today and I've been so
inspired sitting in the green room
watching all these amazing people talk
about their stories my context to the
world is about business I love selling
stuff it's in my DNA it's where I come
from I'm gonna create a little bit of
context with a lot of you right now
actually let's do this to see if I can
avoid it how many people in here have no
idea who I am raise your hand
[ __ ] that hurt but expected what
expected so I'll do that I will create
context I was born in Belarus in the
former Soviet Union in Soviet Russia
I came to America when I was three years
old I grew up in a very immigrant
household eight family members in a
studio apartment 1/8 of the size of this
stage I I love my parents so much
they're my idols the the way my dad
worked the way he created a scenario
where my mom stayed home and really
ultimately the way my mom parented me i
I'm so thankful to be in this great
country and and more importantly so
thankful that I was able to execute
against my DNA when I was five and we
moved to Clark Edison New Jersey my dad
got a job in Clark New Jersey I started
my first business I had eight lemonade
stands and I put all my friends to work
do you guys remember big wheels that
little kind of like bike I used to ride
my big wheels around Edison New Jersey
and picking up my cash at the end of the
day like I was little Tony
soprano or something I wasn't a prima
donna
it's the reason my friends were behind
the register wasn't because I didn't
want to do that work it's because I
walked up and down the streets of Edison
New Jersey and I would literally sit on
the grass for the curb for hours
watching every car drive by to try to
figure out where to put the sign on
which tree or which pole to most likely
sell lemonade
I've always been completely obsessed
with the attention and where the
eyeballs and ears are of the people that
I'm trying to sell my product to when I
was 13 I started my first real big
business I was selling baseball cards in
the malls of New Jersey making two to
three thousand dollars a weekend I don't
know about you guys but when you have 30
G's in cash under your bed and you're 14
and you're not selling weed you're doing
a good job so I was proud of that
that was good my dad then ruined my life
when I was 16 14 excuse me he dragged me
into the liquor store and paid me two
bucks an hour to bag ice for 15 hours a
day so I went from making $3,000 a
weekend doing the thing I loved to
making $30 a day bagging ice for 15
hours a day it was a really big
downgrade it's kind of where my life got
a little bit tough there for a little
bit we are living through the biggest
culture shift of our time my friends we
are living through the biggest culture
shift of our time the internet not
Facebook not Twitter not tumblr
Instagram Pinterest the Internet is
basically only 18 years old right
windows 95 brought us online it's only
been about 18 17 19 years since you
first heard cuckoo Shh
remember nothing I mean do you know
there's some youngsters here we used to
pay three bucks a minute to be on the
Internet
AOL those [ __ ] Jesus
I love social media I love technology
but I don't love it I love the thought
of where my customers going where are
people going how can I tell my story in
the best most efficient way I did not
grow up techy I didn't even have my
first computer until I was 20 years old
I didn't even on the computer until I
was 18 years old this is not something
that I'm like pumped about I'm now
friends with all the coolest kids in
Silicon Valley and we always have these
great business discussions but when it
turns to hey remember your first Apple
2e I'm like no don't talk about this
[ __ ] nerds damn it
what I'm obsessed with is we just heard
some remarkable people and they're
trying to tell their stories and they're
telling them in traditional ways you
can't scale this most people are
fortunate enough this is an amazing
opportunity for all of us to get
together and hear this stuff they go and
they want to be on TV and write books
and be a man is that me hope not
is that me am i gotta go to mike cool
I'm so fired up a breaking [ __ ]
so we're living through the biggest
culture shift of our time three years
ago I started a social media agency and
I work with the biggest brands in the
world luckily we have a big company GE
the NFL Oprah Winfrey Network Pepsi
Kraft Green Mountain Coffee great great
brands and meanwhile their miss
marketing let me ask you guys a question
let's get a little interactive I need
hands
I don't want your half-ass hand I woke
up at four o'clock in the morning to get
here I want full hands ready how many
people here have reconnected with
somebody because of Facebook that they
had not spoken to in over five years
prior to that please raise your hands Oh
weird all of you ten years please raise
your hands 95% of the people in this
room have reconnected with somebody on
Facebook that they had not spoken to in
over ten years because of this platform
I believe that for us to tell our
stories and convert whatever you're
selling whether it's wine whether it's a
concept whether it's any other product
we have to understand that we're living
through the biggest shift of the
attention the eyeballs and ears of
people of our time that many of us are
spending tons of effort and tons of
energy telling stories where people no
longer are we are now spending tons of
our times in new platforms let me ask
you there's another question how many
people in this room in every 24-hour
window even while you're sleeping are
within arm's reach of your telephone
please raise your hands unbelievable 90%
of you this is crack cocaine that was
promised this is it this is the robot we
were all promised but it doesn't doesn't
clean my room we now have to figure out
how to story tell in a world where we're
consuming on this screen where time is a
real problem because we have so much
supply being thrown at us Eric Schmidt
chairman of Google said the amount of
content we're now producing as human
beings in every 48 hour window is equal
to the amount of content music songs
videos information that we created from
the beginning of mankind until 2003 no
wonder our kids are a DD so what you
think your big story or your product or
your awesome service is gonna break
through in that noise we've heard how
many people in this room by show of
hands have
the concept of content is king please
raise your hand just for context for me
quite a bit
content is king it's got to be good
you've got to be good but the word that
I want you to leave with today is
context we are now battling in a war of
context how do we create context to by
permission and equity to then tell you
about my product and service because in
a world where there's that much supply
the shocking thing that nobody's talking
about is the supply of effort and
actually giving a crap about other human
beings that is very limited because
we're busy right remember them when the
world shut off when you got home when
that piece of crap phone wasn't with you
or you couldn't get the information you
could actually live your life you could
do things but now we're on 24/7 365 and
what has happened is we now just don't
care about people as much as we think we
do as a matter of fact I would argue
that over the last fifty to sixty seven
years businesses in general for all the
talk of customers first have been given
a rat's ass about the customer I believe
that every single person in this room's
grandparents are more prepared to be
successful in the future than we are
because the way your grandparents built
their business was through true hustle
and true caring and context small-town
rules my friend
because this is how butcher bob lived
his life butcher bob the second you
walked in started cutting your roast
beef cuz he knew and guess what else if
you went into that shop and butcher bob
screwed with you you would tell
everybody at the PTA meeting and butcher
Bob this business went out of business
that's how local businesses used to go
out because the context of the community
circulated and then that business was
hurt then we started moving we started
moving from downtown suburbs this than
the other thing and we lost our
collective power and then we started
proving to retailers and other services
that we cared about price and we do and
we should but in the world now where
price is a commodity that we now know on
hand at all times we're walking around
with information my friends go your best
buys up dude they're trying to scramble
your mobile information so you can't
walk in a Best Buy and see the Amazon
prices that's a really good way to go
out of business how many people here to
have children that are 12 to 20 I've met
your fastest crap I was good man We Need
to Talk I like that quick draw how many
people in this room have children nieces
or nephews or grandchildren that are in
the ages of 12 to 24 please raise your
hand quite a bit do you remember three
years ago when you had this conversation
hey little Johnny I don't give a crap
how you talk with your other friends but
when your father and mother call you
pick up the damn phone you remember that
just curious how's that working out for
you there are a grown-ass men in this
room that have texted lol and oMG in the
last 24 hours
technology is not your friend technology
doesn't care about the way you view this
new stuff you know what I hate the most
is when I talk to 50 60 70 80 90 year
old so I Gary I didn't grow up with this
I don't get it I didn't grow up with it
you didn't grow up driving and you
figured that [ __ ] out right
this is effort this is psychology this
is a different game yes it's new and
it's different but it's actually quite
funny I like to say as the world is
going more Jetsons
the people in this room that act most
like the Flintstones are going to win
because what's happening my friends is
that we actually appreciate effort the
way I was able to amass 980 thousand
followers on Twitter meanwhile none of
you know who the heck I am is because I
went on summize comm which is now
twitter.com slash search and I brought
value see the reason so many people
struggle with the ROI of social media
and what value does that bring to my
business is because all of you default
into wanting to talk when you first how
many people here the first time they
heard of Twitter thought it was the
dumbest crap they never heard of go
ahead I didn't make it raise your hands
you know what you did because you
defaulted into what are we gonna say who
cares if I'm walking the dog nobody
cares that I'm eating pizza and you
defaulted into the human traits that we
all do and every business does which is
you want to talk back in a day if you
wanted to sell something if you're the
most money you bought a commercial
during happy days 40% of the whole damn
country watched it and you pushed your
message down their throat you put stacks
of it in every store and you sold we are
living through the fragmentation of our
interests and our society because our
eyeballs and ears are going to different
places meanwhile most people continue to
market and try to tell their story like
it's 2005 even though we're going into
2013 we know this because we live it
watch this how many people here besides
live sports DVR or TiVo the far majority
of the TV shows they watch please raise
your hands 85 90 % just curious of all
of you how many of you fast-forward it
every single commercial this year raise
your hand a weird all of you meanwhile
my clients spend tens of millions of
dollars making commercials trying to
reach you and they listen to some
[ __ ] and you
and ratings that tell you they have the
DVR numbers when they can't see the
funny thing is people ask me Gary what's
the ROI of marketing on Facebook and
Twitter and Tumblr and all this stuff I
don't see the ROI meanwhile they're so
worried about the ROI of the new stuff
where everybody oh by the way is quietly
and quickly and loudly going and we're
not respecting the diminishing of the
places where we mark it before we don't
respect the diminishing of TV
consumption I just spoke to the with all
due respect to you the talk I gave
earlier the greatest group of all time
these juniors and you know what they're
watching YouTube they're not watching TV
they're looking in their phone they're
spending their eyeballs and ears in
different places you know what's my
favorite outdoor media I've client spend
millions of dollars on billboards and
and bus stop ads guys do me one favor
you've seen much smarter much more
profound speakers than me but just do me
one little favor
when you go home when you're driving
look out the window and watch five
drivers just five right I promise you
three of them are texting while they're
driving
Oprah is right it's dangerous out there
guys
people aren't looking at outdoor media
they're not even looking at the friggin
road
we all have something we want to say
whether you're b2b or education or b2c
we're all in the same game our consumers
the people we want to tell story to
their eyes and their ears and their
attention it's shifting and it's
shifting really really really fast
yet we continue to hold on to the way it
was the way it's going to be just
curious how many people here clicked a
banner ad willingly in the last year
race it's okay
715 billion dollar industry right so
they think they're doing digital you
think you're doing digital because you
do banner ads you're disrupting my flow
the worst thing in the world right now
is mobile banner ads right you've got
like no screen and you're like putting
this half banner didn't get a rep right
I hate companies by the way if you have
a company you do mobile banner ad I'm
never buying a piece of crap from you in
my entire life there's only one thing
that I'm more guaranteed of then the Sun
comes up tomorrow only one marketers as
a proud one myself marketers ruin
everything
it's what we do we find something shiny
and we squeeze the crap out of it
click through on banner ads in 1994 a
long time ago 71% just a little while
ago 3.0 this year 0.1 how many people
here by show of hands signed up for
Groupon or LivingSocial or gilt groupe
one of these deal the day email services
please raise your hand looks like about
half remember three years ago when you
couldn't wait to get spa treatments that
are 80 bucks for $40 or you just
couldn't wait to get your hands on $80
worth of sushi for $40 remember to add
how great that felt just curious how do
you like those services now you hate
them because they pounded you until you
started bleeding right and now that you
don't give a crap if they're honoring
you a million dollar home for $100
you're like delete spam [ __ ] get the
hell out of here
that's right
over the next four to five years the
people in this room that want to tell a
story sell something move something do
something have to figure out two things
how do you in this world
jab jab jab jab jab jab jab right hook
how do you use things like twitter.com
slash search and search what people are
talking about and realize that we have a
cocktail party going out in the world
right now that you are more than welcome
to join and if you do you're viewed upon
in a good way not a negative way and how
do you build up context to actually have
a relationship so that when you natively
figure out how to talk on Facebook
Twitter Tumblr Pinterest not what all of
you are doing for your businesses and
services which is you're using them as
distribution models you're taking an
email or banner ad or some other video
and you're just sticking it out there
and you're hoping it works and then
you're like but it doesn't work once you
understand how to truly story tell on
these platforms after you've built up
context and emotion you will then start
understanding let me tell you why I
asked you to tell me who you reconnected
with we have more relationships
acquaintances lightweight friends
strangers we carry more relationships
now than our parents and grandparents
ever could because of these platforms
were reconnecting and for a lot of you
you've reconnected with people that you
went to grammar school with or high
school or college so you actually have
context for them their word and their
views on services and products matter so
much more to you than some cockamamie
and banner ad or page 147 vogue or a
radio ad that you happen to hear it
comes with context emotional context to
the relationship which then converts you
at a higher scale this is word-of-mouth
this is what's always mattered but now
because of the maturity of the internet
as it's getting into its early 20s we
are now mapping not just information but
social connections and things like
Facebook have mapped the social graph
but next we're gonna be playing on the
interest graph and the things we care
about and the fact that this information
is out there and we can use it to market
to people is one of the great
opportunities of all time but I'll be
weird in four or five years once
everybody figures out what I'm up to and
what I'm talking about we're all gonna
ruin it and people gonna tweet something
like going skiing this weekend and 50
different ski companies are gonna send
up some free stuff they're gonna
literally send that person free stuff
because it's actually
cheaper for these guys right here to
send me a pair and make me a client by
having the direct relationship versus
renting my attention possibly on
Billboard's and during the Olympics and
all that other horse crap what the
internet is doing is cutting out the
middle and businesses and brands are now
gonna go direct to consumer and actually
build relationship but we're gonna screw
it up you know why cuz every business on
social media right now is acting like a
19 year old dude they're trying to close
on the first move and this actually
takes patience and building an actual
relationship see everybody talks about
acquisition all of you were thinking
about how to get more all of you are
hunters we break down into hunting when
we want to tell our story or sell
something
I'm telling right now we've just gone
through the greatest era of hunting over
the last 70 years and the future of
winning and accomplishing what the hell
you care about in this room is gonna be
figuring out how to be the best hunter
how to be the best farmer that is going
to be the game how to actually keep that
customer how to have lifetime value what
percentage of wallet do you have by
having an emotional context with your
customer you have a shot to win the days
of just talking about how much you love
your customer are coming to an end
because my friends because of these
platforms and you know it for the first
time ever the deers have shotguns they
do and they will talk about the things
you do and so I promise you if you can
figure out how to first care about the
people in your world and your
organization because the only thing more
important in the customer are your
employees and your teammates care about
them trickle back down into the trenches
recognize that the consumers [ __ ]
radar is greater than ever and recognize
that the attention of that consumer is
shifting in front of our eyes figure out
how to natively talk there and actually
give a crap for the first time not just
your bottom line but go for a long play
instead of short term good feelings and
I promise you you'll have a much better
chance of succeeding in the Thank You
economy thank you
I notice I have a minute right we'll
talk slowly so knowing that uh knowing
that we've got I love it knowing that uh
we've got Q&A coming up I'm not gonna be
able to answer everybody's question
knowing with only 20 minutes I can only
go up here I want to eat my own dog food
if you go to twitter.com slash Gary Vee
or facebook.com slash Gary and you have
any question I will stay up until my
eyes are bleeding to answer your
question
thank you what a social media look like
in 2015 is it still 140 characters 2015
you know I like to usually say I don't
know I actually don't usually care about
being Nostradamus and predicting crap
I just want to execute on the reality
instead of what I think all of us are
doing which is marketing like 10 years
ago but in 2015 I can tell you this
I think mobile devices are going to be
the device that carries the information
to us and we have to understand the
dynamics of a world like this I know
that on Facebook if you put a video over
10 seconds that means 10 to 4 hours that
it does worse than if you got 9 seconds
because people in a stream world if they
see 9 seconds will consume it so we're
all desperate to kind of close what
we're trying to close we have to
understand how these platforms work
different than a 30-second spot or a
piece of Direct Mail or a magazine ad
right I know you've advised for some
large companies I know you've advisors
large companies were there several
people in here who runs small companies
or even are just starting their own blog
what advice would you give to them well
that's what I come from right I had a
small family business and so what I can
tell you is this the best part of all of
this guys is that this equalizes the
cash game the big guys are wasting cash
on dumb [ __ ] and you can figure out how
to actually market where the customers
are we are all every person in this room
is in the content business when I
started Wine Library TV on YouTube in
2006 which is really what catapulted me
I didn't want to sell more wine I wanted
to become America's wine guy if you have
expertise or knowledge about your craft
give away the IP that you think is so
valuable give it to the world and watch
what the value comes back to you because
information has never been less valuable
it's all right here remember when being
smart mattered it's all here now thank
you very much Gary
thank you